en ce 9 mai comme chaque année nous
célébrons la fête de l'europe il y à 70
ans les peuples européens ont décidé de
lier leurs destins entre pour assurer la
paix sur notre continent depuis deux ans
l'union européenne a montré sa capacité
à protéger les citoyens européens avec
la dette commune et le plan de relance
commun qui ont permis de sauver nos
entreprises et nos emplois avec les
achats groupés de vaccins qui nous ont
permis collectivement de gagner le pari
de la vaccination
aujourd'hui même alors que les canons
tonnent aux portes de l'europe l'union
européenne montre une nouvelle fois sa
capacité à se dépasser en infligeant des
sanctions sans précédent au régime de
poutine et en assurant par des achats
groupés de gaz que la facture
énergétique des ménages européens
n'explose pas avec la présidence
française de l'union européenne
portaient par emmanuel macron avec nos
eurodéputés il faudra aller plus loin
pour construire une europe plus
solidaire plus démocratique plus
souveraine pour hisser notre europe à
l'avant-garde de la transition
écologique et qu'elle serve d'exemple au
reste du monde alors à celles et ceux
qui veulent aujourd'hui tourné le dos à
l'union européenne nous leur disons
qu'au contraire c'est un formidable
moyen pour construire un avenir meilleur
pour nos enfants bonne fête de l'europe
à toutes et à tous